CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clayman is
here with us so what do you think of
this judge's decision I think it is
stunning I think that it's one thing to
depart down from guidelines the
guidelines been 19 and a half to 24
years but it's another thing to
basically throw the guidelines out the
window which is what happened here we
shorter than what even man affords
attorneys had recommend I think so they
were pleasingly surprised the
prosecutors must have been close to
devastated having tried cases in my own
life from both sides of this you expect
unfortunately in the system of justice
in America that white-collar defendants
do get less time than people of color
even for the same crime how do you
explain it Ricky because it is so
shocking well it's shocking because I
think that you have a judge who was
against this trial from the very
beginning he had reprimanded prosecutors
in front of the jury throughout this
trial he didn't like the idea of the
special prosecutor that was made clear
and he made a decision that as he once
said he is Caesar in his Rome that he
was going to do it his way
but man affort faces up to ten years in
another separate case that he'll be
tried on in DC well that he has pleaded
guilty to and he will be sentenced on
the 13th of March and you're dealing
with a different judge and by the way
very different charges there this is a
fraud case in DC you're dealing with
conspiracy against the United States and
conspiracy to obstruct justice five
years each a maximum of ten the
guidelines bring you to ten real
question for a DC judge Jackson is does
she give him the full ten consecutive or
concurrent and this is a judge who's had
a lot of experience with Paul Manafort
in DC you're dealing with the fact that
she vitiated his plea of guilty and
dealing with a bail it was sunny to hear
after all the damning evidence presented
by the prosecution that this judge
characterized him as living in otherwise
blameless life that was a rather
remarkable comment I think to say the
least it's one thing to look at his age
his health the fat
he did not have any prior record it is
another thing to see someone engaged in
a life of crime for at least 10 years to
call it unblemish and defrauding the
American taxpayers is indeed Thank You
Ricky